all right so former president donald
trump was interviewed in an it can't
even really be called an interview it
was really sort of a softball propaganda
piece it was it was soft propaganda uh
that trump and fox news host sean
hannity did together the big headline
from this interview was that donald
trump said
the haitian immigrants are bringing aids
into the united states um and some
people wrote to me and they said you
know david
there's a lot of aids in haiti in haiti
uh um and and so we have to we have to
consider that let's let's look at the
clip and then we'll talk about it here
is trump explaining it all to sean
hannity and you know there's one other
thing that nobody talks about so we have
hundreds of thousands of people flowing
in from haiti haiti has a tremendous
aids problem
aids is a step beyond age is a
a real bad problem so hundreds of
thousands of people are coming into our
country and if you look at the stats if
you look at the numbers
if you look at just take a look at
what's happening in haiti
a tremendous problem with aids
many of those people will probably have
aids and they're coming into our country
and we don't do anything about it we let
everybody come in so first of all
i was not able to find any reporting
that hundreds of thousands of haitians
are coming in i just i just was not able
to find evidence of that
uh it is true that
there is a higher rate of aids in haiti
than in many other countries that's
absolutely true
it's relevance in terms of what's going
on with immigration
uh particularly
when it is not
a virulently contagious disease
like covid
um
although certainly more serious
it's just weird to make that the focus
again unless you just want to portray a
population as dirty unclean
sick and infected which is like a
classic of authoritarians
towards minority groups that that's
really what it is if you really want to
have a public health
sort of conversation about migration
that can be done
that's not what donald trump is uh is
trying to do here check out this next
segment this is a segment that starts
with hannity asking trump a question
but then he sort of gives the answer and
it's really weird like where where does
the question end and the propaganda
begin you know you you were last time on
this program and i think we need to put
emphasis back on this that your
conversation with the leader of the
taliban before you ever discussed any
deal of withdrawal was number one it was
based on
your your stated threat
that you would obliterate them do you
remember exactly what you said
because i have a source that says you
were brutal to them
and that you said you would destroy them
you would destroy their province you
would destroy it and it would be
everybody in the area would be dead did
you say that everybody
so i what i said and i had a very strong
conversation
i said i hate to start the conversation
this way but that's the way it is
and i said we would do serious serious
harm to them if they killed any of our
soldiers or any american citizen so
really hannity kind of handling the
question and answer for the most part
there um trump then at this point this
is just amazing
trump talks about vaccination and how a
lot of people now don't want the vaccine
i can't tell if trump is this stupid or
if this is deliberate trump says
when i was president everybody wanted
the vaccine
now that biden's president a lot of
people don't as if that's something that
makes trump look good
well you know i was saying the other day
is very interesting
during my administration everybody
wanted the vaccine there was nobody
saying oh gee i don't want to take it
now they say that and that's because
they don't trust the biden
administration i can think of no other
reason
but they say
we don't want it we aren't going to take
it when i was there everybody wanted it
and we were doing great with him yeah
well you know so let me let me translate
that for you
what he means is
under under me
my followers wanted the vaccine
because they thought i made the vaccine
and left wingers wanted it because they
understand science and realized neither
i nor joe biden had anything to do with
the vaccine
under biden left wingers still want the
vaccine because they understand science
and realize that neither trump nor biden
had anything to do with making the
vaccine but suddenly trump's followers
no longer want the vaccine because
they're morons that's what it means and
trump's like that means i'm great aren't
i fantastic as a result of that isn't
that an amazing thing
um trump then says that
the he defeated isis and iran i couldn't
find any evidence of isis in iran but
trump says he did it
we defeated 100
of the isis caliphate
in iraq
and iran
all over but in iraq we knocked out the
by the way we did iran indirectly a very
big favor because they're not big fans
of isis either true but syria we knocked
out a hundred percent and we knocked out
the leadership and we so i was not able
to find any evidence that isis was in
iran i i he's right that iranians have
been very much opposed to isis for a
long time
but just kind of weird we knocked out
isis in iran
and then lastly a completely
unintelligible moment where trump says
something about you never used to hear
the term mandate but that we're in great
shape or something
well you know we never heard the term
mandate but people have to have their
freedoms and we should be in a great
shape between the people who get it they
should not have to if you get covet or
whatever you want to call plenty of name
wuhan virus the china virus you could
call it a we got plenty of names but
well you know we
were you able to understand that
because i certainly wasn't but folks
everything is smelling like this guy
wants to run again in 2024
and horribly he actually might have a
shot at winning